What is the Multiannual Financial Framework?
Often referred to as MFF,
it may sound complicated
but it is simply the EU's long-term budget
It stretches over several years
and funds complex programmes
such as Erasmus and Galileo.
The MFF determines the amounts
that match the EU's priorities.
This in turn ensures stability.
The MFF also sets limits on how much
the European Union will spend
and in which areas.
The main EU institutions
all work to shape the MFF:
EU leaders, who meet in the European
Council to provide political guidance
and the Commission,
the Council and the Parliament
that complete the process
How does the process work?
The Commission makes the initial proposal
Then it's up to the Council,
which has a central role
it ensures all EU countries
are part of the agreement.
Next, the Parliament
is asked to give its consent.
Once it does so,
the Council adopts the MFF
through an unanimous vote.
Find out all you need to know about the MFF
and much more on consilium.europa.eu.